okay
all right unless there's any uh
objection we'll just go in uh Alpha
numerical order and start with House
Bill 1312 and representative leckis you
have a motion I do I
recommend for further legislation for
house bill 1312.
okay
second
seconds
you should speak to your motion sure
um this actually turned out to be uh
very productive this is a reminder the
issue was there was a small business
that's required to put in a
a big grease uh trap when they were
required to
when they change their name a little bit
and you know some thought that the
department was a reasonable to balance
again with respect
excited to sell a few other things
um
so we had a meeting with
representatives from the Department
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services as well as the ability board
turned out that there were some
conflicts between the rules that the two
promulgate in this area
and there was also
um
you know I some on the committee and
others thought that the rules were
too rigid and that the waiver process
which did exist was unclear people
didn't know about it and it's actually
too restrictive so
the folks from those two boards agreed
to go off and meet
and uh come up with some kind of uh
proposal which they did
and they came up with that or maybe
referred to any reason like
it'll be probably be a good idea all
right sorry about that
your subcommittee meeting got top
billing on the house for 11 page
your subcommittee meeting
you got top going on on the web pages as
some of the activities I see
so they came back with a proposal had
some comments on them they revised The
Proposal
and the the end result was something
that everybody involved seemed to be
happy with so what they did is they uh
they've committed to doing some
rulemaking to
um
to get the rules in line so they're not
in conflict and also to loosen up the
requirements um
somewhat to take into account you know
smaller businesses than normal
they're going to drop DS is going to
drop the requirement the minimum size
for grease trap from a thousand to 500
gallons which will make it match the
international plumbing code
and um
modify the criteria for small food
service establishments that would be
permitted to use internal uh
you know they're called hydromechanical
grease traps without having to bury some
great big tank
and they would allow that by rule under
some circumstances and they also loosen
and clarify the rules on getting a
waiver
and so this isn't going to require
legislation they have committed doing
rule making they also committed to
providing additional training to the
inspectors on not only the changes but
also you know the process for
waivers which I guess have been kind of
ad hoc and they're gonna
formalize the process a little bit more
so um you know it was unanimous on the
committee that that sounded like a good
solution and also uh representative
Aaron who is the Prime sponsor of the
bill and uh
you know thought this was fine and also
the business in her District that
prompted this whole thing you know
representative Aaron showed the planned
agreement to them and and they also were
happy with it so
I don't think we need to do anything
further other than you know we can keep
an eye and make sure the rulemaking
actually occurs in the training as they
committed to okay representative Mr
Speaker
thank you madam chair I'll just add that
it was somewhat gratifying to hear that
Des took this as sort of a learning
moment and is has there was a great deal
of cooperation in forming the solution
that they arrived at and I'm hopeful
that that may solve some problems that
could have come to us in the future
without us having to be involved
uh anyone else
I'd like to mention that I went to the
final meeting of the working group
and you're absolutely right Des was
kind of shocked at how convoluted the
process was
and so was Des
and the building code review board
agreed to modify
the plumbing code so that the
requirements of hooking up to a sewer
system were consistent with Des Sewer
Septic requirements
which
because Des had specified one of the
allowable options and said you must use
this option if you're connecting to a
septic tank and therefore the plumbing
code needed to be modified to say that
if you are connecting to a septic tank
you will use this type of pipe
so it
was very useful and I appreciate
representative Aaron from bringing us
this bill but it doesn't need
and legislation at this point
representative sitec so you believe
these people
I I believe I made a comment at the end
saying we need to keep an eye on it to
make sure the rulemaking and training
occurred and there's nothing to prevent
future legislation if they don't they
they seem to be pretty serious and
committed to it so I don't see any
reason not to believe them but you know
you don't trust but verify kind of thing
if you always keep an eye on them yes
January they haven't started into
rulemaking we might want to uh nag them
a bit
and
what else represents high tech again the
clerk notes that representative Schmidt
is not here the Rockies will tumble
Gibraltar will crumble and it almost
never happens
he didn't say why yes representative
Bailey
representative I'm inclined to agree
with Mr representative Lucas but
I'm a little disappointed that none of
this makes whole the people who were the
victims of this
who Must Have Spent tens of thousands of
dollars on this nonsense yes well we
can't make retroactive laws
unfortunately
well unfortunately sorry sorry
yes if if they hadn't decided to go
ahead and install that uh grease trap
the size of their building
we might not have
gotten the chance to get involved in
this
anyone else
all right seeing none the motion is not
recommended for future legislation and
the clerk can call the rule
representative Rhodes yes
the clerk Pro TS represented with cells
yes representative Johnson yeah
representative leckis yes representative
Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes
representative goalie
yes
representative shuitt yes
representative Marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative groda
yes
right the chair yes did I miss anyone
guess not two four six eight ten twelve
thirteen to nothing
all right house bill 1444 registration
of medical spas uh representative garota
thank you madam chair I make a motion
that the subcommittee would like to us
to make a motion that we can it be
recommended for continued legislation
but for the legislation
okay is there a second
thank you
okay would you wish to speak to your
motion representative
during the course of the hearing there
was a resistance from the doctors who
were part of a lobbying group that
actually hadn't been registered with the
state
um they have since registered with the
state and enjoying the subcommittee
hearing
the information that I had gathered from
other medical spas were that the medical
director position
was one where a doctor was actually
being paid for the use of his name in
that profession
and they're available their availability
was not
um
was it wasn't clarified
so they're used their their
representation as the medical director
of that of a facility and in many cases
they are medical directors at many
facilities
um so that they're available it wasn't
clarified
and that
um perhaps a different word instead of
Medical Spa a better word might be
medical cosmetology
so these are recommendations that we
would take with us should we continue
um legislation on this bill
and the Board of Nursing was present at
the hearing any support these changes
and support the bill
who was
I'm sorry was the Board of Nursing okay
thank you you're welcome
uh representative goalie I I have a
question actually yes in what form what
form of legislation are you recommending
a bill what do you mean uh the same
similar where
um oplc would have the authority to
inspect and any
um concerns but they would refer to
the appropriate board
okay thank you
represent goalie do you should speak to
your second
thank you madam chair
um I too agree that
um this should be further looked into as
the medical spas
um
are using drugs such as Botox and such
not
um in their procedures and this would
give oplc the ability to go in and
further inspect and
uh the requirement that uh checking in
to make sure that those are being used
um appropriately
okay
yes representative I would like to also
say that not only with this the new
proposed legislation give oplc authority
to inspect and refer to the appropriate
board but there would be
um the availability of the medical
director will be clarified to something
like 15 minutes so if they if they were
to be called they had to be they'd had
to respond with a specific time
and we would also look at changing the
terminology in the bill from Medical Spa
to Medical cosmetology
okay thank you
representative blackis thank you I have
a question that is what form would you
anticipate
um
sort of the the licensing taker you're
talking about doing a facility license
for it yes similar to what we're going
what we're going to do with the massage
therapist exactly good follow-up
follow-up
um
my understanding is that even like a
doctor's office doesn't have a facility
license
and assuming I'm correct in that you
know what's different about this where
you'd require a facility license for a
place that you know probably isn't doing
things any more hazardous probably less
so than a doctor's office
I disagree
these are medical facilities that are
not doctors offices they perform
services such as not only Botox
injections but filler injections and
um
well there's something else that they do
that I can't really recall but that are
um
putting a foreign substance under your
skin
and that requires
you know certain expertise and if
something should go wrong
because oftentimes a nurse is making
these is conducting these procedures if
something can go wrong and there's no
one to consult with her then the patient
is in a difficult situation
follow-up
um okay I mean I can agree certainly
that can be hazardous
um
but I mean there's some things of
similar Hazard I think that occur at
doctors offices I mean
I I maybe could go along with you know
requiring access to a doctor more
quickly but I question whether it's a
step of uh facility license is actually
necessary so thank you okay
representative Allegro and then Marsh
you know I just want to make 100 sure
that I understand each of the service
providers is licensed under their own
board is that correct
yes okay thank you
representative Marsh uh yes thank you
madam chair I think it's become evident
in the state of New Hampshire that we
have a distinct lack of transparency in
medical disciplinary procedures
um and this is uh pervasive amongst
medical practitioners
um that such that things don't
necessarily become known to the public
that would be coming under the public in
other states the question before us is
whether more legislation is needed I
think what representative grotta is
saying is that the public deserves to
have more transparency because
complications have been known to happen
in some of these elective cosmetic
procedures and whether that legislation
takes the form of more transparency at
the Board of Medicine or whether that
legislation takes the form of Licensing
of these facilities is an open question
not a question before us today but I
firmly believe that more legislation is
needed because I believe we do need more
transparency to deal with the the and we
need more transparency from the Board of
Medicine thank you
I'm sorry Tech the oh
I guess I'm going along with this
recommendation uh I would point out I
think the difference between this and
the doctor's office is a doctor has a
considerably higher level of training
and experience than say a nurse that's
doing the procedure so maybe on with
that toe in the door I'll go along with
this
representative Allegra
although representative I would like to
add that
in general and broadly certainly The
Physician has a wider scope of training
and more training but not necessarily in
a very narrow
procedure that's being performed
so uh you know a physician may have more
experience than an electrician as well
but not in wiring
okay thank you representative
Rhodes
thank you madam chairman uh
representative I if I may have a
question and
I I don't mean for this to sound
defensive but I'm a little bit concerned
about the terminology of medical
cosmetology or medical cosmetologists
whatever you said
um is I think everybody is very clear
that a cosmetologist is not in any way
shape or form
allowed to diagnose any kind of medical
condition so in in the word of
transparency is using that terminology
or creating this term
to make it be more appropriate to what
someone's looking for is that actually
going to confuse the public more into
thinking that
this person is a doctor when they
certainly are not is it's unless I'm
understanding away I might be
misunderstanding what you're saying so
that's why I'm not I'm really not being
defensive I'm really confused on what
you mean by that and I understand and I
thank you for the question that was a
suggestion I'm not saying that's what's
going to happen but they thought that
the word Medical Spa might be might not
indicate the kinds of procedures that
are being done there so medical
cosmetology was a suggestion only
it's not something that would
perhaps be in the future bill
okay
representative scitec representative
Allegro I'm voting to see uh continue
with this not to I'm not voting on the
final bill no
anyone else representative fellows
um I'd just like to say that like I'm a
little concerned about what you call it
too so I'm you know if we if there's a
bill comes up then some research can be
done to figure out what do other states
call this and I think that that would
help but I think another important
reason
um to have them licensed is that we need
to identify specifically what they can
do and what they can't do
we're in
when we first started the subcommittee
on this
the consensus at the first meeting was
that this sort of operation should be
if it's licensed at all it should be
licensed by HHS as the same way they
license other medical facilities because
it is a medical facility and it should
not be licensed in the same way that
barber shops are
and that's something that
I'm concerned that the
the whatever kind of Bill you put in is
going to be
going to have conflicting requirements
and I I believe that if it's a medical
if it's a problem that people are
working outside of their scope of
practice or outside of their knowledge
and experience
that's not an issue for oplc that's a
problem for
the Board of Medicine or the Board of
Nursing or whomever
um
and so I I don't like the idea that you
send oplc in to you know check people
have licenses because
as I said it's it's a medical problem
not a
a licensing issue I haven't heard in any
of the testimony we had that that there
were unlicensed individuals doing things
it was more a matter that licensed
individuals were working outside of
their scope of practice
so I I would be very very hesitant to
vote on on whatever legislation came
through
anyone else
okay
seeing none the motion is for recommend
for further legislation on House Bill
1444 by representative Brodus second by
represent goalie
the clerk can call the rule
representative Rhodes no
corporates yes representative La selves
no
representative Johnson no
Representative leckis no
representative Allegro
represent Bailey no
representative Santo nastasso
no
represent goalie yes representative
shuitt
representative Marsh yes representative
fellows
representative groda
yes
chair
no
um
two or six in favor
fortune eight opposed I guess two four
six eight six to eight the motion fails
okay
so 18 16.
no eight nose
emotion fails okay
they're a different motion from from
someone
okay representative Rhodes
thank you madam chairman I would make a
motion to not recommend uh future
legislation on House Bill 1434.
you know I'll second it okay I've moved
no no recommendation from no further
legislation from representative Rhodes
seconded by representative bleckis do
you wish to speak to your motion no
thank you madam chairs
I think we covered it okay any other
comments questions
all right in that case the motion is no
further legislation and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Rhodes yes
look puts no
uh representative lasalles yes
representative Johnson yes excuse
representative blackis yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Santo nastasso yes representative goalie
no Representative no representative
Marsh no representative fellows no
Representative crota no and the chair
yes
okay uh two four six eight to six the
other way shocking
okay the motion passes
House Bill
1557 representative Goldie I believe
that one's yours
yes thank you madam chair
um as being the prime sponsor of House
Bill 1557 I
move that it is not recommended for
future legislation
and speak to the motion when I have a
second okay I'll second it
uh House Bill 1557 uh the language was
added into
representative Len Zara's Bill house
bill 1497.
um this bill was held over just to make
sure that it went through the full
process and was signed into law by the
governor and it was so this uh bill is
no longer needed because the language
has been adopted and signed by the
governor in another bill
okay and I will say that I
representative goldleaf said everything
necessary
anyone else have a quick comment on this
bill
okay seeing none the motion is no
further legislation on House Bill 1557
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Rhodes yes clerk votes
yes representative La selves yes
representative Johnson yes
representative electus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative legroom
yes okay sorry I didn't hear you
represent Bailey yes representative uh
santoso yes representative goalie yes
for them should yes representative uh
Marsh yes representative fellows yes
representative crota yes and the chair
yes that's 14 to nothing okay motion
passes
uh House Bill 1566
represent Marsh I believe this one's
yours uh yes thank you madam chair um I
move that no further legislation is
necessary as the entire substance of
House Bill 1566 was incorporated by
Amendment to Senate Bill 450 passed and
signed into law by the governor
Excellence there a second
I'll second it okay
you wish to speak to your second
uh no I think that was covered it
okay any further discussion
okay that's in that case the motion is
no further legislation required and the
clerk called the roll
yes you can
well we'll call them he's about to
when I'm ready sorry
representative Rhodes yes
the clerk votes representative lasselles
yes representative Johnson
yes
representative blackis yes
representative Allegro yes
represented Bailey yes representative
Santo nastasso yes represent goalie yes
representative schuit yes representative
Marsh yes representative fellows yes
representative Rhoda yes
and chair yes 14 to nothing all right
the mothers
a lot of snow in the driveway here yes
indeed all right the last one is Senate
Bill 230
on the practice of body art and
representative I believe that's yours
also yes it is thank you madam chair
um
Community subcommittee met and this bill
is similar to House Bill 1429 which we
recommended for further legislation and
the motion for this bill is the same
thank you
seconded by representative shewitt do
you wish to speak to your motion
I think I no I don't representative
shuitt made the second
no okay
just is there any anyone else wish to
comment or question on this
representative scitec uh I had a glimpse
of the committee report a proposed
committee report on this and it was very
reasonable
uh
I have a question of the chair what do I
do if it's a reasonable recommendation
but I don't want any licensing at all
for this
uh vote no
no okay thanks
anyone else have a comment or question
representative Johnson
what was the recommendation because I I
further legislation that's what I
thought I just wanted to clarify okay
doesn't look like anyone else wants to
speak so in that case the clerk can call
the roll when ready almost
representative Rhodes
no
clerklets no Representative lasalles no
representative Johnson
no
Representative electus no
representative Allegro no
representative Bailey no
representative Santo nastasso no
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative Marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative uh groda yes
the chair no
I missed somebody
this isn't adding up there's four two
four six eight
nine oh five to nine
two I said what happened oh I I okay
never mind uh the motion fails of five
to nine
all right does someone wish to make a
different motion
okay
I recommend no future right no future
legislation Madam chair is there a
second
okay seconded by represent the legro do
you wish to speak to your motion
and thank you representative
okay in that case the motion is
recommended no further legislation and
when ready the clerk can call the roll
represented Rhodes yes
representative uh La sells yes
representative Johnson yes
representative lekkis yes representative
Allegro yes representative Bailey yes
representative uh Santo nastasso
yes representative goalie no
representative short no representative
Marsh no representative fellows no
Representative groda no and the chair
yes
so we have
nine to five nine to five okay prevails
motion prevails
all right uh
everyone who made a motion that passed
owes me a committee report at your
earliest convenience
and I think representative Rhodes you
should you should mention the uh
why there's such a split
the unanimous ones are easy but the ones
where the split you ought to report on
why the committee was divided
Okay so
you so representative Goldie Marsh and
Lexus you've got easy ones
as long as it's acceptable we already
have mine
okay I will work on it anybody have
anything else
we'll thank you all for coming and good
luck in your elections
all right
there's a website